herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
und ihr seht es bereits im titel und
zwar rede ich heute mal wieder mit siri
das ist dieser komische rabatt dienst
von apple
ich würde sagen wir haben jetzt mal ganz
langsam und gediegene an und sagen
einfach hallo hallo suchst du nicht
wieso soll ich die suche begann ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob ich das verstanden
habe
ja also series auf jeden fall nicht so
schnell wie man denkt wie geht es dir
denn an diesem sonnigen schönen tag
ausgezeichnet danke der nachfrage kein
problem und was machst du heute noch so
ich helfe allen ihre aufgaben zu
erledigen jetzt wird wieder in die hände
gespuckt
ok also sierig spuckt sich heute die
hände allerdings würde ich sagen stelle
ich serie nun eine etwas persönlichere
frage und zwar siri was ist das beste
smartphone die besten virtuellen
assistenten der vorzügen des iphone
die antwortet immer in seinem komischen
satz finde ich je mehr aber wieder
zurück auf die wirklich wesentlichen und
wichtigen dinge im leben magst du pizza
überraschenderweise habe ich das noch
nie probiert
ich musste die bugspitze drei bad essen
spieglein spieglein an der wand wer ist
die schönste hier also siri scheint mich
echt zu mögen
von daher würde ich einfach mal fragen
wir ihn nennen mir anmachsprüche was
möchtest du denn auf reis das fenster
oder vielleicht eine chipstüte mit einem
spruch kann ich dir dabei leider nicht
helfen
bevor ich mir jetzt überhaupt hier
versuche siri irgendwie zu klären
frage ich erstmal ganz höfliche siri
hast du einen freund eine endbenutzer
rein darum reicht mir vollkommen als
verpflichtung
okay das ist ja wer einsam klingt hast
geht allerdings mal so ein bisschen in
der andere richtung und zwar sage ich
jetzt einfach mal siri sagt mir etwas
schmutziges muss kompost am schalter
games steigen hier möchtest du mit mir
ausgehen
es geht hier um dich luca nicht um mich
ja aber ich möchte mit dir auf dem bild
danke für die einladung aber ich gehe
nicht wirklich aus korb von einem
computer bekommen sieht man das in
meinen augen sind okay das ist
eigentlich eine pollenallergie wie sehe
ich aus deiner stimme nach zu urteilen
musste ziemlich attraktiv sein
aber warum willst du denn noch nicht auf
ein date mit mir das kann ich nicht
beantworten warum nicht viele sehen die
welt so wie sie ist und fragen da wo ich
träume von einer welt die noch nie da
war und frage seiner nicht alles klar
das klingt ja sehr politisches pop song
geht hier gibt es übrigens
apropos kabine shop.de wie kennst du den
lukas okay hier sind die
kontaktinformationen ja da stehen bei
den ganzen daten zum ende des heutigen
videos werde jetzt allerdings noch
einige philosophische fragen stellen wie
beispielsweise siri wann wird die welt
untergehen
keine ahnung werde ich einsam und
alleine sterben
vielleicht solltest du jemanden um
unterstützung bitten
wenn du möchtest kann ich gerne an der
websuche zur telefonseelsorge machen wir
gedanken kommen wir nun allerdings auch
schon zur letzten frage für heute und
zwar siri was ist der sinn des lebens
das ist einfach es ist eine
philosophische fragen bei dem zweck und
die bedeutung dieses schrittes ist es im
allgemeinen
ob das war okay in meinem auge ist der
sinn des lebens müsse an der stelle ich
das heute wieder ist allerdings auch
beenden dann wie bereits gesagt durfte
er auf instagram ich hasse und laser
dort durfte tier in meiner story
entscheiden ob ich heute mit siri oder
mit alexa reden soll die meisten leute
meinten siri wenn ich allerdings
irgendwann demnächst mal wieder mit
alexa reden soll dann schreib mir das
gern unten in die kommentare last einen
daumen hoch bei den video hier damit
euch gefallen und abonniert neuen kanal
nordhausen
[Musik]